i think some things will snap back when
people get vaccinated
i think you know the roaring 20s as
other people
pointed out may not have been completely
accidental that it followed the spanish
flu of 1917.
when we were learning american history
you know when i was growing up i don't
think any of our teachers really
uh linked the two but i think there's
reasons to believe that we could see
some excitement energy that resembles a
bit of the roaring 20s when people
feel the license and the safety to
engage with other people
at some scale like birthday parties
anniversaries
weddings i mean there's a backlog of
weddings like i
i can name seven yeah i got like five
weddings
two or three times i have currently
sitting on like seven weddings and
you know i don't know when they're going
to occur and all of them are going to
occur next fall like august september
october is going to be brutal
they're going to try but the venues
can't handle that you know there's only
so many attractive venues
oh right so there's there's like things
like that which will cause you know what
feels like an explosion of activity when
it's safe
it's perceived to be safe it's
politically safe to have large
gatherings
i think there is some fundamental shifts
around conferences not all conferences
that used to occur going to occur
not all sales meetings that used to be
transacted by flying across the country
in a plane for a three-hour meeting are
going to occur the same way
i think people have shifted their uh or
basically figured out new ways of
calculating the value of their time
and travel and so we may see less
business travel
but they're going to be people who want
to go to concerts there's going to be
people want to see
musicians listen to music and you know
in a group dance parties
things of that sort when it feels safe i
think there's going to be a resurrection
and
i don't know if the movie theaters like
in contrast like ever come back
like because the high the fidelity of a
you know a home audio a home
media system is just so it's so good um
and the convenience is is is superior
uh versus like a concert where
realistically there isn't a home
alternative
you cannot have the same experience of
going to a concert at home
yeah that just doesn't work like yeah
but i thought it was really interesting
if you saw warner brothers or hbo max
that whole
conglomerate they're like you know what
[ __ ] it the whole slate is going out
wonder woman everything's going into our
hbo max service so they're
in a way that's going to accelerate
their competition with netflix and then
disney going all in on disney plus
and being like you know what the all
this does is accelerate them to a better
model
they're going to have a better uh growth
trajectory when we get back on this
quick break i want to talk to you
about what other sectors are going to
stick and which ones maybe revert back
especially
the concept of going back to an office
which i am hearing
a group one group of people i think it's
people with kids who are like
i need to get back to an office i can't
take this anymore and then i got another
group of people who are like i'm
never going back to an office i want to
know what you think the standard becomes
for the big companies and startups when
we get back on this week in startups